what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so I'm sitting here enjoying a casual
morning like I'm eating some steak and
eggs and I'm drinking some coffee and
I'm having a good morning you know I'm
reading over some college that I miss
over the course of the last you know a
week or so and suddenly like my Twitter
feed starts blowing up those you guys
who don't know I have my Twitter feed
going directly to my Mac it goes
directly to my desktop so I see Twitter
and you know see tweets from you guys as
they begin to pop up which I get tons of
them but sometimes I catch my attention
and that's that's why I reply to like
you know a lot of the tweets you guys
sent suddenly my Twitter account starts
blowing up and people are asking me all
these questions
what do you think about fox going into
dizzi what do you guys know what you
guys think about like the x-men the
Fantastic Four over at Disney and I'm
just like what that's crazy talk like
this no Fox would never sell the x-men
and the Fantastic Four does my god man
okay so I jump online and I start
looking at like news and stuff and what
am I seeing their work 21st Century Fox
may sell to Disney Disney might buy it I
didn't even know there was a 21st
Century Fox I have no idea what that is
I knew there was 20th Century Fox I
don't even know what 21st Century Fox is
but supposedly they're the ones that are
holding onto the rights for like the
x-men Fantastic Four and all that kind
of stuff and Disney is supposedly gonna
buy it or at least they're in deals for
that let me tell you something on Amazon
what kind of money does Disney have
Disney's just like hey man you know what
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe
secure doors are kind of running low
nobody wants to go see a movie about
moon night but we got to find a way to
get like the x-men the Fantastic Four
back so you know what we're gonna do
we're just gonna buy the whole studio
that's crazy that's the craziest thing I
ever committed man I wish I had that man
I wish I had that kind of money that's
crazy just buying whole movie studios
because you're just like whatever anyway
if it's true if it's true that Disney is
getting the x-men in the Fantastic Four
man let me tell you something Disney I
want to see Jonathan Hickman Fantastic
Four I don't want to see it now I want
to see it right now do that that movie
dude let me tell you something man if
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four became
a movie it'd be the greatest movie ever
do you guys man y'all have no idea turns
out alright so like Reed Richards has
this genius idea we're gonna run over
the whole plot for Jon and pigments
Fantastic Four I regret nothing
so like Reed Richards has this this
genius idea right that he's like okay
I'm gonna like solve the problem of
everything and then like along the way
or at least like right before that
Norman Osborn had become director of
shield because like Tony Stark was
director for a while after the events of
civil war then Secret Invasion happen
scrolls replacing everybody and then
they're just like how did you not know
this was happening man it's kind of a
big deal so they kicked him out and he
put Norman Osborn in his place because
you know comic logic he does what all
bad guys do and like dismantle zit and
does bad guy stuff so he tries to
conquer the world right like the
Fantastic Four tie-in for this whole
thing is read is talking into a portal
and there's voices talking back to him
so you're like all right man
Reed Richards is going crazy right
whatever slide the whole thing kicks off
and it goes in like Hickman's run and
you find out these voices are like
alternate reality versions of Reed
Richards they'd have all like done
something crazy like they basically
abandon their families and they focus on
this thing called the Council of reeds
which is just like this Council of
inter-dimensional Reed Richards some of
whom have the Infinity Gauntlet some of
whom got the powers of Johnny Storm
instead of the ability to stretch some
became like got the powers of Susan
storm it's absolutely crazy well this
happens well all the stuff is going on
Reed's like hanging out with a council
of reeds this like grizzled old guy like
shows up in the Baxter building right
and then like he goes looking for
Franklin and filaria like oh my god man
things you pop it off like nobody knows
who this guy is
all right Fantastic Four show up they're
like what are you doing with our kids do
puts up a force field and nobody can get
through it then he grabs like the kid
Franklin Richards this little
reality-warping kid whose powers had
been dormant for like ten years in
Marvel Comics like he says something to
him and you don't know what it is and he
goes to valaria the daughter of Reed
Richards and Susan storm facism to her
and you don't know what it is and then
leaves and then like that night Franklin
Richards makes like a universe in his
bed he's like you know what I'm a kid
whatever I just be curious what would it
be like if I made a universe like let's
do that let's just like make a universe
because I'm Franklin Richards buy the
whole story begins to unfold you start
going into the future with this old man
like things are popping off you have no
idea what's happening there's like the
war of the four cities before you find
out they're like the Inhumans on earth
that nobody cares about
also having humans on other planets and
nobody still cares about and like they
end up going to war against each other
and like all kinds of crazy things are
popping off dude like the greatest
moment ever okay so like Annihilus was
this villain from an alternate universe
like a whole nother place called the
negative zone who like invaded the main
Marvel dude he invaded the whole
universe and like attacked everything
with bugs and stuff that was a story
called annihilation it was amazing while
all this is going on Annihilus gets
defeated he gets confined back to the
Phantom Zone somebody breaks in I think
it's like Norman Osborn or somebody like
that somebody breaks in and like
Franklin Richards like freaks out shoots
him with a fake gun that by
real bullets cuz he can like warp
reality but anyway somebody does
something and it ends up opening up the
portal to the negative zone play the
Fantastic Four go in like are we got it
we got to fix this and then like like
Johnny storms like man you guys gotta
get out of here everybody's got to go
heal dude I'm leaving all kinds of stuff
I'm all over the place of the story but
like Johnny storms like man y'all gotta
go it's cool
so like Johnny storms the last one in
there and like the portal closes behind
him he just turns around in like the
greatest moment in comic book history
and it's like flame on it's the coolest
thing ever it is just he's at the last
man standing unleashing holy hell in the
forces of a nihilist dude went out like
a hero
anyway the story goes on and like
Galactus shows up on earth and there's
weird things like the future of the old
man Logan universe like that story it
literally crosses everything in the
Marvel Universe but like Galactus shows
up because like a future version of
himself like crash lands in the present
day and is dead on earth and like the
Silver Surfer finds it he's like I have
no idea what's going on and you're
reading the story and you have no idea
what's going on Silver Surfer goes and
tells Galactus Galactus shows up on
earth and it's like read answer me
what's going on like explain and so
reads just like re so here's everything
that happens so Galactus is like okay
come with me so he goes to the Galactus
and Galactus is like all right man I
don't know if you know but like your
son's powers are back at a hundred
percent and like we need to have a
conversation about this because like I'm
Galactus and like I'm dwarfed by the
power of this kid we need to figure out
what's going on Reed's got no time for
that right like he's going back hanging
out with the Council of reeds one of the
guys of the Council of reeds went to an
alternate universe to try to like fix
things and like the Celestials in that
universe went crazy started calling
themselves like the mad Celestials
conquer the whole universe forced
everybody to worship them anybody who
didn't they killed and like they follow
this alternate version of read back to
like the Council of reeds and this is
the mad Celestials are like dude there's
like this place this nexus so like all
of space-time and we can access all the
other universes out there we can conquer
everything so like they follow them back
all hell breaks loose they attack the
Council of reeds people are freaking out
the Infinity Gauntlet don't work because
they're not in their home universe and
so like everything's going absolutely
nuts so like the main Marvel Universe
reads is like gotta go it's like he
pieces out comes back with guns and
everything whole conflict ends it all
settles down and they're like okay
that's that didn't like the story
progresses for a little while some stuff
happens Reed Richards has like the
Future Foundation which is basically
just like all the smartest kids in the
world hanging out with Reed they get
picks up with like near the end of the
story right like like soon
the storm gets a visit from like this
girl and you're like what in the heck is
going on like who is this chick and
she's like oh hey I'm your daughter from
the future but just so you know things
are gonna get like super bad because
like Reid messed around with the council
of reeds and like it's gonna leave to
like the end of all things so like when
things get at their worst
just pray or something and then like
maybe your prayers will get answered you
know Tolu and like bails off to the
future so he just kind of like all right
this is crazy so like the whole thing
happens like the mad Celestials show up
on the universe the earth is being
attacked by like all these different
aliens and stuff and so like Galactus
shows up like Reid summons and Galactus
is like this is not why I told you to
summon me and he's like yeah man but
like look at the earth like it's being
attacked he's like whatever I'll take
care of it obliterates like 2/3 of the
ship the rest are just like yep not
messing with that they bail out all
right they take off so like Galactus is
here and he's like okay this is the
reason I've come and you're like what's
the reason he's come and then like the
mad celestial show up so you're just
like oh my god things are about to get
crazy these like crazy godly powerful
characters and mad Celestials we're
about to face off against Galactus and
it's gonna be awesome
Galactus gets wretch like it's totally
obliterated like they all like
converging like one giant celestial on
tackle actus and then like they start
attacking the Fantastic Four and Susan
storms like barely holding on and then
there's like a bright light from the sky
and like Franklin Richards and valerian
Richards from the future show up and
you're just like oh my god so then like
like things start getting crazy right
like at like that point things start
getting bonkers alright so like like
Franklin shows up and talked to like his
younger self he's like hey man did you
get what I tell you to do and he's like
yeah man I held all my power come to
find out this grizzled old man from the
future was Franklin Richards from the
future and over the course unlike the
background of everything that was going
on he was teaching his childhood self
how to use his powers and like how to
hold on to them so like adult Franklin
Richards takes like the powers of his
younger self and like combines them with
his own power so he's like twice as
powerful he's like God times 2 so like
Galactus it's like it's like gone and
unconscious right so like like Franklin
Richards goes to fight the Celestials
like the mad Celestials he's getting
ready and he's just like rise to me my
Galactus like resurrects Galactus from
the dead and I was like oh my god dude
this dude is resurrected Galactus this
is the craziest thing I ever seen it's
like Galactus and Franklin Richards
are like fighting against the mad
Celestials and then like like they win
like they end up obliterating the
Celestials and their entire
and then like Galactus and Franklin
Richards like go off and like the far
side of the universe Galactus is like
yeah man so like I guess your god now
just that's Hickman's Fantastic Four and
it's amazing I can't believe we just ran
over that whole thing we were all over
the place but it's such a great story
imagine that in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with like Iron Man and like
Captain America and all kinds like
imagine all that happening like it'd be
the craziest thing ever cause like they
were getting that story and it was like
it's one of the coolest things to ever
happen man dude I really hope this is
true man I'm getting excited right now I
really hope this is true like I really
for real if a true super hope this is
true because if it is it would be it'd
be insane amia magically Avengers vs.
x-men dude man you think infinity war
with sell tickets imagine you see a
trailer for like Avengers versus the
x-men dude up man i'ma tell you son
Matthew won't be able to get tickets for
weeks to go see that movie it would be
insane
it'd be like when jaws first came out
just folks lined around the movie
theater waiting like nine hours to get
in and see that may be the coolest thing
ever it be a do it would be so amazing
man it'd be the coolest thing like it
with the whole Marvel Cinematic Universe
man things will blow up like they'd be
making movies for the next like 50 years
man it would be bonkers man I really
hope it's true I so hope it's true this
is absolutely crazy
I don't even know how to end this video
on your own you know where to go from
here right now post some comments let me
know what you guys think let me know if
you guys think it's true or not if it is
true let me know if you if it's if you
guys think it's true whatever weirdoes
we're just gonna swing for the fences
and say it is true all right so we're
gonna say it's true what story would you
want to see them do in movie form
Punisher kills the Marvel Universe I
would I'd pay $50 to go see that movie
I'd pay an exorbitant amount of money I
mean I'll pay $50 already because movie
theaters are so damn expensive but man I
would up mad pay top dollar to go see
that movie I'd pay good money to go see
that movie but let me know what what
movie you guys would want to see if the
x-man actually end up joining the Marvel
Cinematic Universe alongside the
Fantastic Four
God knows somebody needs to make good
movies about him because Fox ain't been
doing him for like ten years so anyway
let me know what you guys think and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]